Let's dive into using some of the Sequencer tools
inside of the editor itself.
So I'm going to leave this slide up for just a second
to briefly cover the main layout panels within Sequencer.
And it's important to note that you have to have a sequence open.
I'll show you here in just a second
if we don't have an active sequence, how it
will look like the tool is broken.
It's not.
We simply just need to open a sequence,
and we'll have all these at our disposal.
So kind of moving across the top from left to right,
so we have our main toolbar.
We have various different features on here
that we'll cover in a second.
In the second panel over here, we actually have our Outliner.
And this is where we can manage our content that's
in there and our assemblies.
The middle section is our timeline.
So this allows us actually scrub
through the various different frames of our actual sequence
to be able to see and play back everything very traditional
or very similarly related to traditional nonlinear editing.
We can actually just scrub through the timeline
and see everything.
And then at the bottom, we have our playback control.
So this is going to be our time slider, our range
slider, which can allow us to kind of zoom in
on portions of our timeline and see it.
And of course, we can play, reverse, go to the front,
go to the back, et cetera.
So let's go ahead and jump over to the engine.
Now I've got our map open.
So this is our sequence 905.
And within our content browser, under sequence 105,
maps is the sequence 105 game dev, which is open.
Now I already have the sequence that is open here.
So just to show you real quick,
so I'm going to close out Sequencer.
So see, it closes the sequence.
And if I were to go up to Window,
and what we're going to look for is underneath Cinematics,
Sequencer, if I open this, it will appear
like the tool is broken.
It's not.
Again, what we need to do is we
need to actually load a sequence.
So from within the engine itself,
or at least within this map, you
can see just this little dropdown here,
which is our level sequences.
There is this MSQ 101.
And I could click this, and it should open my sequence.
You'll also notice, because we have it within our world,
it's also available over here in our Outliner.
So by simply clicking it, you'll
see there is a open level sequence within the Details
panel.
Either method that you use will get you the same results.
So down here, inside of our sequence,
now we get to see all of our controls.
Now, if you've opened this and you scrub this back,
you'll notice that the camera is decoupled.
All we simply need to do is in our Camera Cuts
track within the sequence, click the little Camera
button, and it will lock the camera to your viewport.
So you can see now as we scrub through,
we'll actually see our entire sequence play out.
All right, so to cover just the Sequencer
UI that's available, so we've got Save, we've got Open,
we've got a couple of tools as well to create cameras
or even export.
Across the middle section here, we've
got various different actions that we can do.
These are worth looking into.
We also have View Capability, so you can see here
we can actually turn and off different features.
These are really quality of life
that allows you to work faster or have better recognition
and readability on your sequence.
Keep moving across here, you can see as well we have some
playback options as well.
A couple really handy key features
that I definitely recommend when it comes to working
with Sequencer is this concept of that we're
going to be keying certain actions or certain attributes
on our actor.
So for example, if I select our little purple guy here,
and I'll scroll down, you'll notice
that inside of the transform here,
we have various different keys.
I'll highlight those real quick.
And those keys are just traditional animation principles
where we record basically a value on our timeline
that says, hey, when the playback range reaches
this specific spot, I want these values to be present.
So with this, whenever we create key frames,
we can do it one of two ways.
We can create it manually each and every time.
So for example, if I move my character, I'll go in here
and I'll click my little plus button to set a key.
I could do that every time I wanted to change a property,
or we can work just a little bit smarter
or make our lives a little bit easier by using Auto Key.
So when this is turned on, I'll highlight over this
that says, creates a key when channels or properties change.
Now something important to note is
that only automatically adds a key when there's already
a track and at least one key.
So a good typical workflow here is
I would take my character underneath my transforms.
I can hit this plus button as opposed
to the plus button on the individual channels,
and it will create a key for all of my properties.
In fact, you can see that right here.
Let me kind of zoom in a little bit.
So you can see that we have these three keys
for our location, rotation, and scale.
And then we can continue to build out our shot
with Auto Key turned on.
And as I move my playback range,
you'll notice that as I move the player
inside of the viewport,
it'll actually just create a key frame
for only the changed properties.
Now again, in order for Auto Keyframe to work,
you have to have some key frames present.
So if you notice from our keys,
we are only changing location,
we're not rotating or scaling,
and the engine's automatically created a key frame for us
by using this Auto Keyframe.
All right, so now that it's understood,
you'll see here from this dropdown,
key change, the default behavior,
key group, key all, are some other things.
And then without going too deep
on key frame interpolation,
you'll see that we can specify
whatever the default key is.
All right, so you can see this is a great feature.
So this is allows all edits,
allow sequencer edits only, allow level edits.
If you recall in the previous video,
we talked about how we can have possessables and spawnables.
So as we're animating our content
or whatever it is inside of our sequence,
you'll see that we can actually make edits
both in the world or in the sequence
or in the world separate.
So this is very handy.
There are special cases where you do want to use this,
but by using allow all edits,
you should be completely fine.
And then finally we have our snapping.
So this is gonna allow us to snap our key frames,
also allow us to snap our grid.
So this is very handy.
Playback range here.
So something that's very important to note here
is by changing your FPS,
you're not effectively changing the overall compression
or your final output.
Because we're working within a digital medium,
we're really not confined to a,
this is your FPS if that makes sense.
But instead this is going to be your playback speed.
You can dynamically change this at any point.
However, the biggest recommendation I have
is determine what your playback rate is going to be prior
and try to just stick that
throughout the entire production.
Now, traditionally in game development,
we use 30 frames per second.
It feels cinematic.
It's easier on the player.
And as we start pumping more content,
obviously the higher FPS that you go
requires more hardware resources.
So using something like 30 frames per second
is absolutely a safe bet
when it comes to game development.
One of the other tools kind of bridging off
of this concept we're talking about
with animation key frames and creating these
is at any point, so I'm just gonna select my transform.
You can open up the curve editor
and the curve editor is going to show you
all of those key frames.
Now in the case of this example, I have the bot lock.
That's why I can't select the key frames and move those.
So I don't accidentally change anything,
but if it were unlocked, you could see here
that I could go and select the key frames,
move them, manipulate them.
Very traditional animation to be able to get the look,
the feel, the movement, the timing
that you're looking for.
And we can do that through the curve editor.
So moving on to the second section.
In fact, we've already kind of been working with it.
You'll see that this is essentially
just our content assembly.
Now, inside of this sequence that we're using,
you'll see that we've got various different folders.
We have some cinema cameras.
As you saw in the previous example,
we're obviously manipulating the little bot that's in here.
I've also organized some various lighting
that we're using, our events,
our triggers that we have here.
So essentially this is just our assembly area,
very similar to our outliner.
But in this case, we're only seeing the content
that is being controlled, manipulated or displayed
by Sequencer, not our actual world content,
which is still available over here.
So we talked about the curves editor,
which is a great way to refine your motion,
your animation, and your timing.
One of the other things that we will actually be building
in a later course is the events manager.
So a very cool and very handy feature of Sequencer
is that it allows us to essentially cross talk
between our sequence and the world itself.
So we can do things like firing off events.
We can trigger certain elements as well.
For the purposes of this class and what we're building
and then the subsequent class that's after this,
we'll actually be using events to target
an events manager.
The whole principle here is that we're building
a quick cut scene.
And at some point during our sequence,
we want the player to invoke some kind of action.
When this case is just, hey, we need you to press
a button to confirm that you acknowledge
what the NPC wants you to do.
So we can do that by using events.
So that way we're building our world smarter.
So we have a blueprint that essentially contains
the logic for our player controls to pause our sequence
to, okay, the player chose this action, go do this,
which exists outside of our sequence.
So by using the events feature within sequence,
we can actually target that, fire off different commands
back and forth, and it won't really give this player
this feeling of they're in control of the narrative,
all while using Sequencer.
Something else to keep in mind is that
Unreal ships with a lot of pre-built templates.
And these are great for getting you started.
But one thing that's very key to understanding
about the way these templates work
and how you can use them.
So templates aren't a special version of the engine, right?
So if I use the games template and I use first person
versus, oh no, I need to create a third person.
It's important to note that it's the exact same engine.
In fact, every single one of our project templates
uses the same engine.
So the question is, well, why use a template?
Well, templates do fundamentally two things.
So the first thing is that it will actually include
this content for you when you create your project.
So example, if we were using a first person shooter,
obviously we would want to have the arms and a weapon rig
and we'd wanna have a player camera
that when you possess will appear as a first person, right?
Now that's gonna be different from a third person
or even a top down.
So when you create your template,
the engine is gonna automatically give you this content
within its own special folder.
So typically you'll see something like TP underscore
first person, TP underscore third person,
or something that's its own standalone folder
within your project.
All right, so that's the first principle
about understanding templates.
The second thing is that templates
will automatically flag various different features
within the project.
So if you recall, underneath our plugins,
we could go in and we can enable certain things.
Now, for example, let's say that we're creating
a blank project, but it wants to,
we wanna use like an open world, right?
There are a few features or a few pieces of content
or plugins that the engine typically would use
in that process.
So when you choose that template,
the engine is going to drop in some example content
for you, and then it's also going to enable
those plugins that you need.
As a counterpoint, now I know we're talking
about game development, but when it comes to automotive,
product design and manufacturing, typically speaking,
you're looking for the highest quality rendering.
You're not looking for ultra high frames per second,
but rather the highest visual quality.
So by using the automotive product design
and manufacturing template, the engine is going to
go ahead and change a few settings in the project
to ramp up the visuals, which will obviously degrade
our performance, but again, that's intended.
We want better visuals over high frames per second.
It will enable certain plugins, and then it will even drop
in some example content of a pre-built scene specifically
for that automotive and product design and manufacturing.
So hopefully that makes sense.
At any point, you can always go back
and remove content from a template.
You can copy that template over to a new project.
You can even go in and disable the plugins altogether
that you don't need anymore.
So just know that when you start with a template,
it doesn't mean that you're stuck.
You can't change it, you can't alter it.
At any point, you absolutely can.
Now, another cool feature on the whole subject
of templates is we can actually create
a templated sequence.
Now, this is a more advanced topic.
We're going to be creating a sequence from scratch
so we kind of understand the process of building it,
but a really cool feature that's been in the engine
for quite a while is on the main toolbar
underneath our cinematics, we have this add level sequence
with shots.
And that's going to open up this sequence or this master
sequence shot settings in which we can allow the engine
to pre-allocate and pre-build various different folder
structures, the naming conventions
we have for our shots, for our subsequences, et cetera.
My best recommendation rather than
us going through these settings is to play with this.
Now, it's important, go ahead and set your base path
if you are in an active project to a folder that's
not going to touch any of your existing content
so you can see what's actually occurring.
So in this case, this is the default,
just to highlight real quick.
So it will give name sequence, suffix of root.
You'll see that it's created five shots.
Now, if I skip down to this little screenshot here,
you'll see we have our five shots established.
And they have the same length,
which is going to be our five seconds here.
We can do shot directories, first shot numbers,
takes, et cetera.
This is very handy if you want to get a master sequence set up
very, very quickly with it already pre-populated.
So I highly recommend, again, on the main toolbar,
click the little film snap box here.
And you'll see there's an add level sequence with shots.
Go ahead and create a level sequence with shots.
And just take a look at how that is set up.